[Musique]
le point de départ pour découvrir le
travail de gaillac kusama c'est
justement le point où les quoi comme
l'indiquent la commissaire de
l'exposition
chez rothschild le point les poids et
c'est vraiment ça marque l'idée pour
elle c'est que on est tous des petits
points dans l'univers et
d'explorer cette question de lille vers
quillan les cosmos qui on parle enfin et
comment est ce qu'on peut se retrouver
là dedans faire remonter des questions
crise existentielle
de yokohama est né en 1929 au japon elle
débarque aux états unis à la fin des
années 50 où elle côtoie de grands noms
de l'art contemporain comme georgia
outre donald judd ou andy warhol
rapidement agir et
[Musique]
59 60 elle a commencé vraiment avoir une
politique favorable qui a propulsé un
cahier à l'international prolifique
l'artiste japonaise yayoi kusama a
touché au cours de sa longue carrière
plusieurs formes d'art peintures
sculptures performance mais pour le
grand public ces salles de miroirs
infinie sont probablement ces oeuvres
les plus connues la fondation fille en
présente deux dans cette exposition
gratuite
c'est une expérience qui est calme en
qui amène une certaine tranquillité un
renfort qui est important et intéressant
quand on pense au travail de tous
seulement parce que elle a aussi vécu
des troubles de santé mentale des
hallucinations l'angoissent et s elle se
sert de son travail pour canaliser ses
peurs ses angoisses ses questions
en effet depuis la fin des années 70
l'artiste aujourd'hui âgé de 93 ans
habite dans une hôpital psychiatrique au
japon qui n'empêche pas de régulièrement
aller à son atelier de continuer à crier
et nous faire réfléchir sur notre monde
et son travail plaît il attire les
foules cette astuce horizons politiques
déstabilisant
définitivement c'est vraiment
merveilleux chaque oeuvre d'art se
complète d'une pièce alors ça fait je
sers bien compléter tout
l'exposition est présentée jusqu'au mois
de janvier à la fondation fille marco tu
vas demande il faut réserver ses billets
davance le 15 de chaque mois des
nouveaux billets sont mis en vente ici
lady alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal
[Musique]